Prof: Last time--so last
time we discussed two factors
that limited--that retarded and
limited your progress.
Remember, I'm describing that
Europe was in a pretty bad
situation.
One was sort of
mental--cultural,
there was a mindset that
largely focused on the
supernatural and did not have
that mindset to question
received wisdom and to test
whatever they believed against
what they saw in reality.
The second was a food and
population balance that left
vast numbers of people in
conditions of near starvation.
Around 1750--around 1700,
Europe started to outgrow these
limitations and we started
talking about that last time.
We saw how the scientific
revolution,
given great impetus by Newton,
he wasn't the only one but the
fabulous success in explaining
the universe that Newton's three
very simple laws--
you learned that certainly in
high school if not in junior
high school--
explained how all the heavens
work and that was an amazing
creation of the human mind and
it had tremendous import and
started what's been called the
Enlightenment.
That sort of changed the mental
set into something more
progressive,
and then as you've read in--I
hope in your course packet the
introduction of foods from
America sort of cut down--
got rid of the physical
limitation on population and
economic well being in Europe,
that the amount of food went
way up.
So this--especially the
food--increased the European
population.
There's all kinds of different
numbers available but anywhere
from 62% up to a doubling of the
European population due to the
introduction of American foods.
Now the standard belief about
population at that time was that
population is a wonderful thing.
Jean-Jacques Rousseau who we've
talked about,
who was abandoning his own
children by the car load to
control his individual
family's--
the number of children they had
to cope with--
in terms when he thought about
the grand--
the political system he said,
"that government under
which the citizens do most
increase and multiply is
infallibly the best.
Similarly, the government under
which a people diminishes in
number and wastes away is the
worst."
He's very clear that not only
is high population good but it's
infallibly good.
Benjamin Franklin,
around 1751,
argues about this.
"There were upwards of one
million English souls in
America,"
This is before the Revolution.
"This million doubling
supposed but once in 25
years," which is not a bad
estimate of the doubling time of
American population at that
time, due largely to
immigration.
"Doubling once every 25
years, within and another--will,
in another century be more than
the people of England.
What an accession of power that
will be."
And the realization of American
increase in numbers and
therefore increase in power was
very important in the history of
that time.
After the French and Indian
War, before our Revolution that
you know of,
the settlement that the English
got Canada,
which was barren wasn't worth
very much at the time,
and the French kept the islands
in the Atlantic which were very
rich,
sugar and plantations,
slavery of course.
The French kept those and the
English took Canada.
Why?
To keep the Americans in check
because they knew that the
Americans would get very strong.
Thomas Jefferson often said,
'population is power,' so in
1800 when the U.S.
was only ten years old,
so very fragile in terms of our
military strength and everything
like that.
Napoleon had recently--Spain
had owned Louisiana which was
the whole vast territory to the
west of the 13 colonies,
and during the Napoleonic Wars,
Napoleon got charge of them.
He was going to send French
troops there to occupy Louisiana
because they were such a big and
important territory,
but the U.S.,
of course, objected.
We were having this huge
population growth,
immigration,
they were flooding over the
Appalachian Mountains into the
territories.
The next boundary was the
Mississippi River,
and America did not want any of
the European powers taking
control there.
The French Ambassador in
America realized that America
was growing so rapidly in power
and he thought Napoleon's idea
to send troops was stupid,
that Napoleon would lose the
war.
This guy was very clever,
he did one thing,
he sent to Napoleon a summary
of the American Census of 1800.
Remember that in The
Constitution we have to take a
census.
There was one taken in 1800 and
it showed such a great rate of
American population increase
that that's all he had to send.
It showed that the U.S.
population was doubling every
22 years, not the 25 that
Benjamin Franklin had estimated.
Napoleon got the message
immediately;
there was no way that France
was going to be able to hold
Louisiana against American
objections.
What did Napoleon do?
Sold it to us for a pittance,
basically a pittance,
because he knew he could not
hold it;
the power of population.
Now why did governments love
large populations?
Why was it power?
Two things, one a lot of men
and what do you do with men?
Take them into the army so you
have big military power,
also more people farm more
land, produce more food,
and other goods.
Then what can you do?
You can tax it,
so the governments get a lot of
tax and a lot of people if they
have a big population.
There was no question in
anyone's mind that a big and
growing population was just a
wonderful sort of thing.
What they didn't realize is one
of the things that I'm trying to
get across in this class,
that that system works for a
situation where you have no
limitation on land or resources.
It's like I've been--I was
describing for Africa where the
population was small and land
was large,
then population is--can be a
benefit in the way just
described.
The reality,
for Europe especially,
was different.
After 1750, again largely due
to the American foods,
people filled the European
countrysides to overflowing
capacity.
These are quotes from various
sources back then.
"Mountains spilled over
with people, cities grew and the
plains became full,
but this increase in population
brought more mouths to feed.
Population rose and the
resources could not match the
population."
When you have more consumers
then goods,
law of supply and demand,
prices rose,
people couldn't afford what
they previously could afford,
and poverty deepened.
In this period in Europe people
often moved--migrated seasonally
to get jobs because they didn't
have enough income from their
own land.
They would go to where some
harvest--
they were needed to harvest or
needed to work on a building
project,
but at this time this
population of people wandering
around looking for some sort of
work increased so much that the
line between migration and
vagabondage,
becoming just a vagabond,
was crossed by hundreds of
thousands of Europeans.
They were just wandering around
looking for some kind of work to
keep them alive for a little bit
longer.
This was written--noticed and
written about a lot at the time.
They flooded the highways,
roads were opening up at the
time.
They flooded the highways of
France, Germany,
the low countries,
all of these places this was
noticed.
Children at the time--again you
read there's crowded orphanages
and foundling homes,
women and children--very large
number of beggars arose at this
time.
Women and children begged on
church steps and on roadsides.
This problem of poverty as I've
mentioned was much observed,
much worried about,
much commented upon,
and in fact,
all of the great intellectuals
of the day,
whose names we still know,
commented upon it.
You all know Edward Gibbon?
Gibbon wrote,
The Decline and Fall of the
Roman Empire,
one of the most famous
intellectuals of that time.
Right after that he wrote,
"In the civilized world
the most numerous class is
condemned to ignorance and
poverty."
Why were people poor?
Well the general consideration
then: they were poor because
they were in some way deficient.
The idea was that God had given
some people--
kings and aristocrats--the
abilities and capability to rule
and all the others were
relegated to the lower classes.
They just didn't--they had bad
heredity,
they were lazy,
they were "the wrong
sort," they were inherently
incapable that their nature,
their human nature,
they didn't really have genetic
ideas back then,
was to be incapable of leading
the good kind of life.
Well, this was a nice theory
and people who are upper class
enough to get an education to
write about it could live
comfortably with that theory.
Then America opens up for
colonization and guess what
happens?
Who moves to America?
The poorest people,
especially from England.
The lower classes moved to
Australia at a somewhat later
time,
and then they empty out the
prisons going to Australia so
they have really the lower
classes.
What happens to America?
As I've just showed you the
people work hard,
they're industrious,
they make a lot of money,
they get ahead,
everything looks very good in
America and so the theory just
didn't fit observation.
As I've mentioned,
people are, by now,
paying attention to what's
around them and this idea that
Americans had been so poor in
England but they moved to
America and things get better.
The question arose:
why were the poor so poor in
England?
Kind of an obvious question;
again not the first time that
this question had been asked.
The Bible, and again sorry
for--keep referring to religion
but you cannot,
just cannot discuss Western
intellectual history without
going there because that was the
basis of the way people thought.
What the Bible says,
Ecclesiastes,
'when goods increase they are
increased that eat them.'
If you have more stuff,
population grows and they eat
the food.
Very close to what we'll see
Malthus says later.
Edmund Burke,
who as you know is now
considered the father of
conservative political
philosophy: "The laboring
people are only poor because
they are numerous;
numbers in their nature imply
poverty."
In a fair distribution--what
liberals were saying share
equally,
"In a fair distribution
among a vast multitude none can
have much."
He was talking against
spreading the wealth because
under that condition if you
spread the wealth everybody is
extremely poor.
Those kind of thoughts started
people thinking about the
relationship between population
and resources.
What was that?
There's this sort of a fairly
new way of thinking about
things.
Where did they turn to?
Again, in the spirit of the
Enlightenment,
science was the leading source
of intellectual new ideas and
natural history was going on--
was getting going at that time,
studying of plants and animals
in their natural habitats,
just like all your TAs for this
course.
Adam Smith, among others,
paid great attention to what
the naturalists were saying.
In The Wealth of
Nations,
1776, "Every species of
animal naturally multiples in
proportion to the means of their
subsistence and no species can
ever multiply beyond it."
Then he explicitly says,
"Men, like all other
animals, naturally multiply in
proportion to their means of
subsistence."
So he's immediately applying an
ecological law from the study of
animals to people.
Well how fast can humans
multiply?
David Hume, another one of the
luminous philosophers,
1742: "Almost every man
who thinks he can maintain a
family will have one,
and the human species at this
rate of propagation would more
than double every
generation."
Adam Smith again got some of
the problem;
he realized that if wages
increased, if things started to
get better and wages increased,
this would lead to an increase
in population.
He explicitly says,
if people have more money
they're going to be able to feed
their children more and they
will stay alive,
and there will be a decline in
mortality,
and the population will grow.
He--very surprising--did not
close the circle and did not--
never apparently realized that
this growth in the population
would mean more competitors for
the jobs and would push wages
back down again.
That was the great achievement
of Malthus--and all this
interest in what is the cause of
poverty, and there were many
other things.
There was an enclosure movement
in England at the time where the
lands on which the peasants had
lived were being closed in and
controlled by the squires,
the country squires and so
forth;
a lot of other things going on.
This was the kind of
argumentation that was going on
at the time.
Malthus was the one that
realized that population and
wages and mortality were in a
negative--what we now call a
negative feedback loop.
If wages increased,
as I've just said,
then population grows and if
population grows the competition
for jobs and for food and for
everything else pushes wages
back down,
or pushes prices back up so if
you earn the same you're still
getting less.
In short, although the
population could grow and the
economy on a gross scale could
grow, the per capita income,
he basically said,
could not grow.
In the strongest statement of
this,
and he went through many
editions with many different
statements,
but in the strongest statement
economic progress is basically
impossible;
looked at from the point of
view of per capita income,
the living standards of the
average person.
Malthus was very clever and
thought more deeply about it and
he was aware of two
contradictory changes that were
happening throughout the
eighteenth century;
he writes in 1798,
at the end of the eighteenth
century.
As I've mentioned and you've
read there's no question that
agriculture was improving,
not only American foods,
but also agronomy was coming in
as a science and people were
learning,
even with the same crops,
to improve the crops,
to improve their livestock,
to fertilize better,
to rotate fields better.
They were learning to grow more
food.
Nevertheless,
even though there was more food
around poverty was growing,
and that was also very clear at
the time.
His argument is based on a few
very simple kinds of statements.
Contrary to some previous
thinkers who envisioned the
relation between population and
resources as there's a fixed
amount of resources.
There's a pie.
We now use the expression pie;
there's a pie and depending on
how many people there are you
divide the pie into smaller and
smaller slices.
The more people,
the smaller slices of the pie.
That is completely wrong and
never has been correct.
All people do some kind of work
and the pie grows with each
person some--
the pie grows to a certain
degree and the question is how
much does the pie grow?
For instance again,
in the United States at the
time,
we had these vast lands to the
west where we were killing or
had killed the Indians and they
were very few of them anyway,
so that allowed each new
person--so as the population
grows--
again when you have no
limitation of resources--
a new family is living on the
frontier,
the frontier becomes crowded.
American population was growing
very fast;
they were having lots of kids,
lots of immigrants,
where do the new people go?
They just move some miles to
the west and they get a
beautiful new farm and the land
is just as good as what was left
behind and they grow as much as
the farmers that they left
behind.
The population increases,
the gross economy increases,
and the per capita standard of
living does not decrease because
this guy has the same amount of
resources as the previous
generation had.
This was not the condition in
Europe, or in England,
or the rest of--actually all
across Eurasia.
Here the law of diminishing
returns takes effect because
land starts to be limiting.
When land is limiting--people
are naturally smart,
what do they do?
If there's beautiful land,
fertile land by a river,
of course they farm that first,
and so as the population grows
that gets taken up,
all the good land comes under
the plow and is good.
Population keeps growing,
well the next set of people
have to go to less good land,
maybe drier land,
maybe hillier land,
and their productivity is not
quite as good as the previous
group that got the best land.
Population keeps growing and
people have to move high on the
mountaintops,
into dry areas,
into desert areas,
into swampy areas,
in all kinds of areas where
their production is not going to
be as high.
The average income,
from say farming,
decreases as you use less good
land and so things--
conditions get worse and
finally all the land is used up
and there's no land for farmers
whatsoever.
This is the law of diminishing
returns.
If you travel around you can
really see the law of
diminishing returns happen--
a mix of how people always do
some work,
but when there isn't much
resource to take advantage of
they can accomplish very little.
Quite a few years ago I was
traveling in the highlands of
Bolivia and Peru,
and a lot of native Indian
markets there--
very colorful,
tourists love to go to them--
but you watch the ladies sit
down and they have a blanket in
front of them and they display
their wares and they--
it's all agricultural and
they'll have maybe a few fruits,
and a little bit of this and a
little bit of that,
and they have almost nothing,
almost no stock on the blanket.
They've grown this over the
past say months or something;
they've walked all the way
maybe even days to get to a
market, and then they have very
little to sell.
Even if they could sell
everything that they brought at
some sort of a profit they
didn't have enough--
their total amount that they
would take home was still very,
very little.
They were producing some,
but not very much.
In the cities--I have to tell
you one story.
I was in Lima in Peru,
this same trip,
and a lot of street vendors
doing stuff and I saw one guy
had a pair of socks up there,
and he had some sort of a
knitting needle or something.
He was holding up the sock and
as he was talking to the crowd,
jabbing the sock with his
knitting needle,
and he was saying,
'You can't destroy this sock.
You can't destroy this sock.
It'll last the rest of your
life.' Bash, bash,
bash.
I'm watching for a while and
I'm skeptical but the socks
seemed okay.
I thought, the poor guy;
I bought the pair of socks.
Those socks,
I could not destroy them,
I used them for about 20 years.
It was really true.
He was making some sort of a
meager living but it wasn't
good.
If he had a better job,
if there were more resources
that he could utilize--his low
wages would not drag down the
average.
You must realize of course that
when one says a phrase like
that,
that he could--there were
resources that he could
utilize--
brings up a vast consideration
of power and everything else.
What other resources and who
gets to utilize them and so
forth.
It's a much more--of course I
say a little bit and there's
much, much more to say about all
of these things.
The law of diminishing returns
reduces the average
productivity,
but there's a counter-veiling
trend which he also was aware of
that I've just mentioned.
That the productivity of the
land was increasing,
again through the new foods and
new agricultural technologies.
These two factors work in
opposite directions,
and Malthus had to make some
sort of a guess as to how these
two factors would balance out.
Which would predominate?
Would the introduction of new
technology improve faster than
the law of diminishing returns
decreased it,
and his conclusion was that
technology would be somewhat
stronger then the law of
diminishing returns so that
total productivity--
per capita productivity and
would indeed keep increasing.
He thought it would increase
sort of at a constant sort of a
rate.
In graph terms,
let me see if I can get right
to this graph--here's--this is
the standard kind of graph about
Malthus.
Here is the way he thought that
resources,
mostly food in his--in the
case--the time that he was
talking about--
he thought they would increase
in a more or less regular way,
per every year if you consider
these years.
Every year would increase by
about the same amount.
He called that an arithmetic
growth.
We now call it a linear growth.
He and everyone else knew that
population can grow faster than
that, so you probably understand
a little bit about exponential
growth.
If each couple has four
surviving children,
not unreasonable when there's a
moderate amount of food,
and then these children have
four and so on,
the population does not grow
4,6, 8,
10,12--a linear kind of thing.
It grows 4,8,
16,32, 64 you're used to
counting this way from bits.
That's called exponential
growth where each generation
doubles or improves by some
percentage.
I've just made this graph at
growing 10% a year.
No matter where you--and the
growth is like that,
that's an exponential curve,
and all exponential curves look
like that,
you can change your scales but
they all look exactly like that.
It doesn't matter where you
start.
You can start in England where
these two curves would be pretty
much matched at the time Malthus
was writing or you can start in
America where resources are way
above population at the
beginning,
but then you just wait,
America starts filling up more
and more rapidly,
as the population grows.
10% of a large population adds
more people in a year then 10%
of a small population,
so as time goes on the
increment per year gets bigger
and bigger,
and eventually it outruns
resource growth.
This was Malthus' mathematical
formulation of his ideas and he
believed it to be an
inevitability that this was an
iron law of economics,
and that you couldn't avoid
this and so human population was
doomed to a per capita misery
kind of thing.
He put it in this particular
mathematical form,
but as you can see,
the mathematical form doesn't
really matter.
As long as population can grow
faster than resources you're
eventually going to get into
this situation.
Even if population grows
linearly, if it grows at a
faster pace than resources,
you're back into this
situation.
The idea, the simple idea is
that population can grow
faster than resources and I
think that's for sure true.
Malthus was certainly partly
correct.
He was right and he was also
wrong,
and he has been--you've
probably heard Malthus always
gets discussed since he wrote a
big subject of controversy,
and I think the current sort of
fashion is to,
is to put him down.
How many people have heard
discussions of Malthus?
In how many does he come out
well?
How many does he come out badly?
It's about split.
In certain kinds of circles
it's unfashionable to be a
Malthusian nowadays.
He was right and he was wrong,
and what was he right about?
First he had
apparently--although the
historians argue about
this--quite an accurate
description.
This Malthusian situation is an
accurate description of Europe
from about 1200 to into the
1700s,
so for about 500 years very
strong arguments can be made
with whatever data is available
that Europe was in this
Malthusian trap.
It also, as I'll show you in a
minute,
that as the industrial
revolution took hold,
he was still right for almost
another century,
and then things changed.
He didn't have this--he had a
crystal ball,
he was pretty good,
but he didn't have a real
modern model crystal ball.
There are two things that he
did not foresee.
He lived at the very beginning
of the industrial revolution and
didn't really realize it's
power.
So when he saw it,
he thought he thought
production of all sorts,
not only agriculture,
would increase kind of linearly
but constant increments every
year,
but in fact the way it has
turned out is that not only can
population increase
exponentially,
but production can increase
and for the same reason
basically.
When you produce,
if you're in this scientific--
this post enlightenment era
where we know science makes life
better--
then as your economy increases
you have more money and you
devote a certain fraction of it
to research,
to a technology and so as your
economy grows every year you put
more and more money into
research,
so in the same way that if it's
a percentage of your total
income--
total national income or
something that you invest,
and you get a good product out
of it then just like population,
every year you will have more
income,
more gross national product,
more when you invest a certain
fraction you have more,
and also technology and science
grows exponentially.
What happened is that
eventually technology
grew--production--just as fast
as population,
and in fact,
somewhat faster than
population.
We sort of realized that when
we say that our economy grows
like 2% a year we don't say--
we sometimes say it grew by a
$100 million dollars year,
something like that,
but more often--
which is a linear statement,
$100 million,
$100 million--but if you say 2%
then next year you have 2% of
102%,
and then next year 2% of 104%,
it grows faster and faster.
Again, this kind of percentage
increase in technology in
production has exactly the same
limit as population.
That there must be no external
limits;
no resources that are limiting.
Now of course we realize we do
have to worry about the limits
of the environment.
People have multiplied;
people have basically filled up
the earth and the--
we're using everything that
looks like we're using virtually
everything that humans can use,
and there's not much left.
So the question is,
can we continue to increase our
production?
We don't know the answer to it.
The second thing that Malthus
didn't foresee was a big drop in
the birth rate.
He again, acting sort of in the
Newtonian mode of pronouncing
scientific laws that were
inviolable,
and inevitable,
he said the sex drive was an
instinct--
people liked sex--and that
would not go away so they would
keep reproducing.
Now he was also aware of
contraception,
people were doing various
things even at that time,
and it was certainly an
awareness.
He was so--he was a
minister--he was so morally
opposed to that that he just
would not really consider that
people would ever do that,
so he dismissed that kind of
idea.
What happened,
that in some sense makes him
wrong,
is that after about another 100
years after he writes,
production increases enough to
keep up with population and the
birth rate starts dropping and
we're going to talk about both
of these--
both of those things.
When you think about Malthus
getting into these discussions
that the strict formulation of
his ideas,
that we can't make any economic
progress and disaster is
imminent,
that's clearly not the case,
but if you just slightly
rephrase his questions and ask
not whether you have a dead stop
to population growth--
to economic growth--but that in
those countries and those places
with very dense populations,
even though economic growth is
present there,
would the people be better off
with a lesser population?
Is Malthus right not in the
extreme but in the reality that
you can--
even in very dense
populations--you can have some
economic growth,
but would the people be better
off if they had less--
a lower population?
Then instead of asking whether
food is your limiting factor,
asking whether the environment
is your limiting factor and
that--
with those rather small changes
in what he said makes Malthus as
relevant today as at any time.
Let's look at some of the
things that I've been talking
about.
You've all seen--you've seen
this graph before and you
remember this is for Roman times
but characteristic up to--
from way, way back almost into
the 1700s.
that 1,000 females are born,
not very different for males,
most of them die--about half of
them die as infants,
then childbirth and they keep
dying and eventually there's
very few left.
This is the number that are
born and the number that are
left.
The reason I show this again is
because there's one number here
that I didn't describe before,
but is one way of
characterizing this
E_0 is--
E is for the expectancy of
life, how long you're going to
live at age 0,
at your birth.
When a child is born how long
do you expect them to live?
Of course that may be say 70
years old nowadays.
My mother, for instance,
is 97 and so her life
expectancy is like 102,
so the life expectancy depends
on when you're measuring it and
so this is life expectancy at
birth and at this time it was
just under 21 years of age.
We've see here that when the
death rate is such as to have
this kind of a life expectancy,
that something like a third of
the women are doing all the
reproducing because the others
are dead,
and if it's a third they have
to have six children to keep the
population going,
but since a lot of that third
is infertile or sick,
or unmarried or whatever,
the average has to be six--
the women who actually can
reproduce have to produce a lot
more.
It turns out that that's about
the limit.
That much--with an expectancy
of life of much less than that,
much less than 20 or even maybe
get it down to 20,
your group, your population
goes extinct.
Think mathematically just a
little bit that if the average
lifespan is 20 years then in
every one of those 20 years,
an equal number every year,
1/20^(th) of the population is
going to die and 1/20^(th) is
5%.
You can think of a 5% death
rate as sort of the maximum.
5% of the population dies every
year is kind of a maximum that
humans can sustain.
More than that and you have a
lower E_0;
your population goes out of
existence.
As time goes on,
I've shown you this slide also,
conditions get a little better
so here is the way this graph--
this is rather stylized,
we don't have great data to
make such a graph,
but this shows the life
expectancy between 20 and 25
years,
which we think is more or less
the characteristic of humans for
a long time,
and then very slowly over
thousands of years it gets
better,
and up here you're maybe at 25.
At 20--at 25 years,
so 25 years--if people are
going to live on average 25
years that means 1/25^(th) of
them die every year,
1/25^(th) is 4%.
When you see a death rate of
4%, which can be expressed as 4
per 100 or 40 per 1,000--did I
say 40%?
I meant 4%.
What has happened over these
thousands of years is that we
managed to keep 1% more people
alive every year.
From here we're keeping the
death rate as maybe 5% a year
and the death rate here is maybe
4% a year,
so keep those numbers in mind
as a primitive kind of minimum
using say the 25,
that 40 per 1,000 deaths and
the population is going to be
fairly stable,
so 40 per 1,000 people.
That's what was going on
through most of human history.
Now if you look at the actual
numbers for Europe,
you see that Eastern Europe has
a--this is the death rate of not
40 per 1,000 but 38 per 1,000
here.
Very, very little bit better
than the rate at which you
really can't keep your
population alive anymore.
This continues in Eastern
Europe until 1860,
until Civil War time.
This is the Civil War in
America.
Russia frees its Serfs at about
this time;
you've got a lot of the great
Russian authors and musicians
who are starting at around that
time.
So in Eastern Europe if you
measure standard of living by
the death rate,
the death rate has improved
very little over the 40 or 50;
50 is from thousands of years
ago--then the 40.
Then modernization takes over
and it falls very slowly.
Western Europe,
where the enlightenment hit
first,
is doing better at this time,
and the line is sort of where
Genghis Khan--
the line between Eastern and
Western Europe was basically
where Genghis Khan--
the Mongols occupied Europe.
Here in 1800 Western Europe
already has a death rate down to
28.
Remember I told you in the
1700s the Western foods come in
and things start getting better,
so the death rate has been
dropping at least all during the
1700s and depending on what
historian you read,
possibly before the 1700s.
Eastern Europe 100 years later,
this is 1800 and this is 1890,
Eastern Europe is 100 years
behind Western Europe,
more than 100 years.
Europe has already--Western
Europe has progressed somewhat
and at this level the population
is increasing quite rapidly.
During this period,
again population is increasing,
resources and production are
increasing somewhat,
but the balance is not in favor
of standard of living.
For instance food.
Grain accounts for,
during this period,
about 80% of the calories of
the poor and even for the upper
classes who had more meat,
and eggs, and this kind of
stuff it was about 50%.
You can look basically at grain
prices and wages and grain
prices and tell how the people
were living.
In Strasburg,
which is very favorably
situated on land on the Rhine,
just on the border between
Germany and France,
sometimes it's Germany and
sometimes it's France,
between 1400 and 1500 for
instance,
the amount of work needed to
purchase a month's worth of
wheat was in the range of 60 to
80 hours.
This is just before the
Reformation for instance,
60 to 80 hours.
By 1540, populations were
already increasing,
it had risen to over 100 hours
and it doesn't--
and then it keeps going and it
doesn't come back down to 100
hours until the 1880s.
We're talking very;
very late the people are not
living better.
The wages of German workers,
again measured in grain,
because prices go up and down,
but how much grain can you buy
whether you work is the
important number.
It fell roughly 50% between
1500 and 1650.
The percentage of males in
Frankfurt in Germany with enough
property to be citizens fell
from 75% in 1723 to 33% in 1811.
We're watching the population
get impoverished.
Massive unemployment in Germany
caused wages to fall below
subsistence levels,
especially in the 1840s,
and living standards in Germany
showed no signs of improvement
before 1850 at the earliest.
We're talking very modern
times, well into the industrial
revolution, and things are not
getting better if you look at
per capita income.
Again, population is growing,
the total national economy is
growing, but per capita you're
not improving.
In England, buying power
started falling in the 1500s and
didn't recover to that level
until well into the nineteenth
century.
In Paris, bread consumption did
not increase per capita,
did not increase between 1637
and 1854.
Pastureland didn't increase,
so the same amount of meat
basically was produced with some
improvement because of some
cattle breeding,
but now it was divided among
more people,
and not only that,
but because potatoes had come
in and potatoes could keep more
people alive,
a lot of pastureland was taken
away from pastureland and put
into potatoes so basically meat
became very scarce in European
diets.
Again, it decreased between the
Middle Ages and 1800,
it doesn't start recovering.
Forests did not increase,
in fact were cut down to have
more land for agriculture,
so wood becomes scarce for
housing,
for heating,
for heating houses,
for building houses and so
forth.
What happened during this
period is that people--
standard of living was going
down, they managed to stay
alive,
they had to work harder and
harder,
the hours that they worked to
get--to maintain themselves
alive kept increasing and yet
they didn't make any progress.
We're talking about ballpark
100 years into the industrial
revolution which we now--
that's what you learned in high
school,
the industrial revolution is
such a wonderful thing and it
improved incomes and the modern
world during the industrial
revolution.
But in actual fact the data
shows that's really not the
case,
that for about 100 years the
industrial revolution while
making tremendous progress and
total national economies are
growing very big,
the per capita income of all
but the very upper classes
doesn't really grow.
By this time of course Malthus
is dead and we know he's been
laughing in his grave because he
was very controversial.
When he was alive he was very
controversial and it really
wasn't until the Irish potato
famine,
about which you have read,
and massive numbers of people
died for lack of resources,
a bug killing the potatoes.
Then people said,
'oh yeah Malthus was right,'
and then it kept going.
His idea that progress could
just be eaten up by population
growth turns out to be
characteristic of many hundreds
of years of European history and
the rest of the world also of
course.
Now an amazing thing happens in
this to start changing the story
and it happens in France.
What happens?
The French, which looked up
until about 1800,1750 or so,
looked like any other
population in Europe.
They had lots and lots of
children, but then they stopped
having a lot of children.
It just came out of the blue,
and what changed?
The age of marriage didn't
change a lot so that wasn't the
cause of it.
The age at first birth didn't
change a lot,
they weren't getting married
then delaying childbirth,
that stayed about the same.
The interval between babies
didn't change very much so they
were not using much control
within marriage apparently.
Once they got married they just
started popping out babies.
But, they stopped having
children at a young age.
The age of--the age at first
birth doesn't change much,
the age at last birth changes
by ten years.
Families stop having children
about ten years earlier,
chopping out a very large
fraction of their fertile years.
This behavior is called
"stopping behavior"
and we see it all around the
world eventually.
No one understood what was
going on but they were
horrified,
they knew it was happening,
it was--
people were well aware of it
and they were quite horrified by
it.
Any of you that watch
television know that John Adams
and his wife Abigail went to
Europe about that time,
I think it was 1782,
and she especially was
distressed at the French
people's "feeble commitment
to family life,"
exemplified by the French
families only having three or
four children rather than the
eight or ten that you were
supposed to have.
Americans at the time were
having eight or nine.
They were equally
horrified--this is again from
the Adams', they were equally
horrified by the French upper
classes easy acceptance of
adultery.
This they found was,
and this is John Adams
speaking, "an indication of
the general moral and social
disintegration."
He said, "The French are
not a moral people."
What happens is all this
behavior which was wildly
decried by everyone,
within a century after France
starts doing it,
all of Europe takes off and
starts doing the same thing.
Here is a graph of that.
This graph starts in the year,
and we'll talk about it later,
where fertility has already
dropped by about 10% and here's
France and this states that--
when the fertility change has
already been going on to the
1820s,
when it's actually started
before that,
and then every other country in
Europe starts dropping its
fertility within this period.
It goes down by--in this space
of time--by 30%,
an enormous change.
Even though France starts it
early and everybody's horrified
by it, in fact,
everybody starts copying this.
This is Europe but in another
century, Asia,
and Latin America--follow suit.
This is really a major change
in what it means and how one
lives life as a human being.
I've stressed the biology of
reproduction,
of course we have a biological
drive to keep having sex and
that produces children.
The culture or the cultural
religion presses upon people to
keep their birth rates up and
this goes on for thousands and
thousands of years of human
history until the late 1800s,
early for France and then all
of a sudden all around Europe
and then later in the world this
very fundamental way of being a
human changes.
The big question in demography,
since this was noticed a long
time ago, what cause this
change?
Why did all of a sudden with
no--why did this all happen?
The people at the time were
absolutely dumbfounded,
and dumbfounded especially that
it should happen in France,
because at that time France was
at the height of its power,
it was about the richest
country in Europe,
it was the most powerful,
it was the most advanced in
learning,
all the Philosophes were there,
the encyclopedia was there,
it was the top of the world.
Why should, of all places on
earth, the richest people on
earth--stop having children?
Now--it wasn't important at
that time,
it wasn't considered to be
important,
but of course France is a
totally Catholic country and so
why should a Catholic country be
the first one and way ahead of
everyone else to reduce its
birthrate?
Historians have come up with
all--we don't know the answer,
let me tell you that right out.
But, historians do have lots of
answer for it.
One--the reasons for the French
fertility decline lie in the
moral and religious
reassessments that occurred in
the tumultuous years of the
French Revolution.
For sure, a moral realignment
was certainly taking place.
How many of you know Madame
Bovary, the novel?
What's the novel--what's the
centerpiece of the novel?
It's an adulterous affair,
right?
Here's a woman,
a young married woman,
has a child,
and she has a perfectly nice
husband who adores her and is
quite permissive.
She really has nothing
objective to complain about,
but she considers him boring
and so she takes an exciting
lover or a series of lovers.
I'm not going to give away the
plot but the book was taken as a
justification for having
extramarital affairs.
Now that's okay for men and has
been okay for men,
but here's a woman,
here's Flaubert justifying a
woman's having an extramarital
affair,
not because the husband was
beating her or anything,
he was a perfectly decent guy.
That was considered terrible
and he was promptly arrested and
prosecuted by the government for
"affronting religious
morality."
Of course that was very good
for sales of the book,
so everybody read that book,
including a lot of us still at
Yale.
People were--the rest of Europe
were well aware of the French
lead in this and in English
speaking countries France was
blamed for the problem,
and especially French novels,
and they were corrupting our
people,
they were fomenting
extramarital liaisons,
and by implication the use of
contraception.
This spreads very rapidly so
who knows the plot of Anna
Karenina?
An adulterous affair,
and again, her husband wasn't
quite as nice as Bovary.
He was kind of a stiff guy but
he wasn't beating her;
he wasn't really a bad guy,
she goes off and has a wild
affair and that--
War and Peace and
Anna Karenina,
and The Brothers
Karmazov, one of the three
greatest Russian novels,
are exactly on this same mode
of Flaubert and they're all
really talking about this whole
change in attitude toward
fertility and sexuality that was
overcoming Europe at this time.
Much later, not that much
later, after the European
fertility transition was over,
which only lasted until about
1930.
It starts in 1870,
you'll see these dates,
the fertility drop out--except
for France starts in about 1870
and is all over by 1930 and
social sciences start thinking
about this fertility drop but
not in moralistic terms anymore,
not how it was ruining our
morals, but in terms of sort of
quantifiable explanations.
The major--again asking this,
which is probably the most
important question in all the
social sciences,
the most important change in
how it is to be a human,
and what is the cause of this?
They did a very massive project
and we'll have a guest speaker
who's one of the main people in
this,
Michael Teitelbaum,
that they set up what they call
an office of population research
and they did--
every graduate student got a
different country in Europe,
and he went into that country
and looked at all the provincial
records and dug out everything
they could find and they got a
mass of statistics on everything
they could figure out about
every province in Europe,
and not only Western Europe but
all the way across Europe into
Russia and so it was the most--
probably the most massive
social science investigation
that ever took place.
What had come up by that time
already was kind of a schema of
what's--what we now call the
demographic transition.
I've shown you how the death
rate, there's no particular
dates,
this is sort of very
generalized kind of idea,
that the death rate--the first
thing that happens in time is
that the death rate falls.
Then at some time later the
birth rate falls--
there's--early on I described
the drop in the death rate and
now we see that sometime later
the birth rate fall happens.
Well what happens in between is
this population growth.
In old times the birth rate was
very high and the death rate was
very high,
but they pretty nearly matched,
there's a little bit of
difference,
the population does grow but it
grows very slowly.
When it's all over,
the birth rate is low and the
death rate is low,
and again there's a little
difference.
Population grows slowly,
or nowadays in a lot of Europe
the birth rate goes below the
death rate and population
decreases somewhat slowly,
but there's no super rapid
change here,
there's no big rapid change
here, but in between the death--
the time when the death rate
falls and the time when the
birth rate falls--
all of this is population
growth because the birth rate is
above the death rate.
This is the period of the
population explosions and the
first of these population
explosions was in Europe,
not in the poor countries,
not in the developing world,
but in the richest part of the
world at that time which was
Europe.
The same schema is supposed to
apply later on.
This is, as an empirical
generalization
medium--that some countries fit
this.
Nobody is terribly far from
this, the birth rate and the
death rate always go down in
some relationship to each other,
but the question which arises
is, is the correlation good
enough that the death rate
actually--
the drop in the death rate
actually causes the drop in the
birth rate,
and the theory runs in a rather
obvious way,
that parents know how many
children they want.
They know roughly how many
children they can keep alive,
how much farmland they have to
give them to inherit,
how many they need to take care
of them in their old age.
When the death rate is very
high, and not only high but very
variable--
I showed you last time in
Sweden the death rate going up
and down,
when the death rate is high and
variable you don't know--
if you have a lot of children
you don't how many are going to
survive.
You need not only as many
children as you want,
and taking into account the
death rate, but taking into
account the variability of the
death rate.
What if an epidemic comes
through when my kids are young?
So you have to have a lot of
children in order to insure that
in your old age you'll have some
to take care of you.
As the death rate falls people
gradually really--
the theory is that people
gradually realize this and they
reduce their fertility because
they don't need to bear so many
children in order to have so
many left at the end because the
children--
they start getting confidence
that the children are not going
to die.
This is a lovely theory and how
many of you have heard that,
some version of that?
It's one of--you'll see there's
about ten standard
versions--theories about why
fertility falls,
this is number one.
That it's the fall in the death
rate causes the fall in the
birth rate, so now we're going
to--this is--look and see how
accurate that this is.
This is Norway actually,
and here is the death rate--
this black line for Norway--and
it starts falling from about
middle of the 1700s,
and pretty continuous fall
during all this time.
Here is the birth rate,
pretty constant across here and
then it finally starts falling
in 1900 I think,
so there's a long time period
between when the birth rate
starts falling and--
sorry when the death rate
starts falling and when the
birth rate starts falling.
The difference between those
rates is this line here that all
of this is population growth,
and in this period here where
the death rate is quite a ways
down but the birth rate hasn't
responded very much yet,
the Norwegian population grows
by this amount.
That's standard,
that's the way it's supposed to
work.
That's the way the schema shows
it working.
Now you look at England,
England and Wales,
and you don't get this picture.
Here is fertility,
the gray thing,
and fertility starts dropping
as I said around 1870,
maybe 18--this shows it a
little bit after 1875 or so,
and then it drops rather
continuously.
This is fertility.
Infant mortality,
which is a good measure of
total mortality,
doesn't really start dropping,
it's pretty constant,
ups and downs,
until 1905 or something like
that and it only starts going
down.
Here it's the reverse situation
that now you have fertility
falling first and mortality
falling later,
and you can make a causal
explanation for this,
that when people are having
lots and lots of kids they can't
take care of them.
They don't have enough food,
they don't have enough this,
that and the other thing,
so there's a very high death
rate among the children.
If you drop your fertility you
have more resources for each
child.
And that's actually as
compelling an explanation--in
the absence of data--as the
reverse explanation.
If you look across many,
many countries which the
Princeton project did,
this is the drop in the
mortality rate,
this graph, and this is the
drop in the fertility rate.
This is the years,
same year starts in 1825,
this is 1975,
so this is the period when the
change was happening and for
fertility here this period is
when birth rate has already come
down by about 10% and you'll see
that's some kind of threshold,
and when it's down then
something like 30% I think it
ends and mortality has also its
limits.
This is the period when
mortality is falling in Norway
and Denmark, and Sweden and
England, and Wales and so forth.
All you have to do is look at
the order of these things.
As I've shown you for
fertility, France is the first
one by a long shot it starts--
they put it in the early 1800s,
it's down by 10% already and
it's all over by 1900 or so,
France way ahead in time of
anybody else.
Now you look at the mortality
and you say well where is
France?
It's not Norway,
it's not Denmark,
it's not Sweden,
where is France?
Do I even see France here?
There it is.
Its way in the middle of the
pack, that doesn't fit the
theory and if you go the other
way,
Norway is the first one to drop
its mortality rate and where is
Norway,
more or less in the middle of
the pack when you look at
fertility.
These two things don't
correlate as nicely.
Again, this is the Princeton
project;
don't correlate as nicely as
the theory would have us do.
The end result of all these
graduate students studying the
relationship between mortality
and fertility was?
We don't know what's going on
because we saw everything under
the sun.
There's no very strong
correlation.
They were very smart and they
tried all kinds of things and
another way you can look at it
is to see at what level of
mortality,
maybe looking at years is not
the right thing but the level of
mortality.
They looked at infant mortality
levels at the time when the
fertility dropped.
What you have is,
in France, the infant mortality
was still very high;
just infants it's not total
mortality just infant mortality,
almost 300 here when France
starts dropping its fertility
sometime this--
puts it somewhere in the late
1700s.
The fertility started dropping
and the infant mortality was
still very high.
Then you can go around the
world all different kinds of
places,
Japan 160, Norway 100,
that there doesn't seem to be
any kind of commonality here in
what the infant mortality
actually was when fertility
drops.
Remember the 400 is sort of the
primitive level,
and actually when you go into
Asia you can see that in places
like Taiwan and Mexico--
Mexico doesn't--that moved from
Asia.
In Mexico and Taiwan the
mortality was 35 ,
so very close to the primitive
level where you can just keep
your society going and yet
fertility starts dropping.
Basically you see the whole
range.
The whole range is something
like 35 or 40 and you don't keep
your society alive less than
that,
and modern Japan would be at
this time be about 5 and you see
that--
the range is what you actually
see is this whole range,
anywhere in that range of what
mortality levels people actually
achieve can be the range at
which fertility starts to fall.
There's no real conclusion
possible.
What's explanation number two
that you all have heard?
Economic development,
how many have heard that
explanation?
Not so many,
that's very standard,
the whole Reagan--
the whole Reagan policy
was--and for a lot of the world
was that--
forget about family planning
and pushing that,
that economic development is
what reduces fertility so that's
a very good theory also and we
can look at it and wow the data
looks pretty good.
Down here is per capita income
and each of these is a separate
country here,
for every country as per capita
income goes up fertility comes
down.
It can come down a fairly
straight line,
or it can do some wiggles and
jiggles, but basically as per
capita income goes up fertility
goes down.
You like that theory?
There's some problems with it.
How much money does it take to
keep people out of bed
basically?
Well, the French start dropping
their fertility when their per
capita income is something like
180--
this is in--converted basically
to dollars $180 a year,
50 cents a day,
back then that was more money
than now,
it keeps the Frenchmen out of
bed.
Now anybody of Italian
extraction will be very proud to
realize that it takes Italians
twice as much,
$360 or something to keep them
out of bed.
We have now scientifically and
quantitatively proven that
Italians are definitely sexier
then French people.
Then you go along,
here's the Germans a little bit
stolid here,
and of course who--we are at
exactly the opposite of what we
presume that the English are
supposed to be so straight that
they don't do it at all and yet
in order to keep the British out
of bed you have to really pay
them awful lot.
They have to be somewhere in
the--between $700 and $800
dollars in income.
There doesn't seem to be any
particular number of income that
has a huge range that is
required before people drop
their fertility.
When you think about it a
little more this whole way of
looking at it is not very
convincing because here's per
capita income,
but we're talking about the
time of industrialization and
after fertility starts dropping.
So once fertility starts
dropping per capita income does
start rising.
That's sort of the most
important take home message for
today,
so I'll say it before time runs
out,
that the industrial revolution
by itself didn't really improve
the standard of living of
people.
Up until about 1870 there was
tremendous increase in
productivity,
population.
They cancelled each other out
and for the average working
person the standard of living
does not rise.
Starting roughly 1870,
people dropped their fertility
rates and the standard of living
starts rising and we see it
starts rising all along here.
If you take any dates from 1870
until today or until a few
months ago anyway,
per capita income is rising
everywhere in Europe at
different rates,
but everywhere in Europe.
Anything is for guessing,
in everything that you can
measure about Europe,
changes in what we call
monotonic in a single direction.
Education goes up,
urbanization goes up,
the number of the year goes up,
everything,
women's education goes up,
anything that you can think of
goes up,
and fertility goes down.
So when you make graphs like
that anything that you put on
this axis is going up.
This happened to be per capita
income,
it could be education,
industrialization,
urbanization,
and fertility is falling during
this period--
so any two variables that you
put together will give you
similar graph to this and it
tells you absolutely nothing
except the only thing you can
think of that--
well there is no particular
level of income which causes
people to drop.
When you get into the
developing worlds the levels are
way, way below,
they're out here and they start
dropping their fertility levels.
They repeated this over and
over again for all kinds of
hypotheses and they always got
the same kind of answer that
nothing really correlated very
well.
Literacy is another answer that
people started getting more
worldly because they can read,
and fertility began to fall and
literacy rates were very low in
France and Bulgaria,
in Hungary but literacy was
already very high in England and
Wales when its fertility fell.
Urbanization,
the British fertility declined
when it began in Britain in
1870,
72% of the British were already
in what are called conurbations,
in urban settings,
but in France when they started
100 years earlier,
very, very low level.
I won't continue this but that
Princeton project was a massive,
massive study of all the--every
socio economic variable that you
can think of,
all the theories,
all the ten theories that you
hear around and from your
friends and think yourself,
none of them really worked out
as something you could really
nail to fertility drops because
of infant mortality drops,
or income goes up,
or education goes up,
or any of these sorts of things.
Next time we will continue and
tell you at least what the
Princeton people thought was the
real cause.